hey folks right up top I have some
opinions about Monday's bands and those
opinions obviously didn't fit into this
video because it's a precon review I
made a separate video that went up on my
patreon that gave some of my thoughts
and I also included a portion of that
video at the end of this one so you can
stick around for that if you want to
know some of my thoughts with that said
let's talk about a preconstructed
commander deck From Dusk Mor that my
patrons picked out for me to review
endless punishment what I'm going to do
in this video is talk about what this
deck is trying to do what I like about
the deck and what I change about the
deck to improve it this particular deck
sees Wizards of the Coast delving into
an archetype relatively unexplored in
preons of the past group Slug and this
particular deck is a pretty powerful
showing this begins with the commander
vavo Herer of souls is a four Mana four4
flyer in rapose colors with Ward pay2
life and whenever an opponent loses life
for the first time during each of their
turns put a plus one plus one counter on
vavo and draw a card the first thing I
notice about this card is that it's a
strong payoff for a very specific action
causing opponents to lose life on their
own turns there are all manner of
vaguely sluggy cards that this can work
well with but there's one specific type
of card that this really goes to town
with and that's cards that deal damage
to opponents on each of their turns the
prototypical example in my mind is
sulfuric Vortex but there are a number
of similar cards in rose colors as well
as underworld dreams type cards that
deal damage to players when they draw
cards these go hard with vavo because
they allow a player to draw three
additional cards per turn cycle putting
three plus one plus1 counters on vavo as
well this will translate into a pretty
backbreaking amount of advantage and
since a lot of cards that do this with
bavo cost three Mana it's theoretically
quite easy to set this up by turn four
going into this deck I was kind of
curious how much of this sort of thing
the precon would be packing and the
answer is honestly more than I expected
there are 11 different cards that I'd
expect to trigger life loss more often
than not on each opponent's turn and an
additional 15 cards that will at least
sometimes trigger life loss on an
opposing turn Beyond these there are an
additional 10 cards that will cause some
sort of Life loss to opponents at
sorcery speed and it seems like this
sort of incremental chip damage is how
this deck is looking to close out the
game a small part of this package seems
to be a combination of cards that draw
opponents additional cards and cards
that damage opponents when they draw
this is backed up by a b removal Suite
that packs answers for a wide range of
threats finally a small package worth of
Life gain is here to keep the deck alive
when the heat turns up overall this deck
is looking to build Advantage with its
Commander while gradually knocking down
opposing life totals through a broad
range of different cards that can dish
out incremental damage so that's the
game plan but how do I like what's going
on here overall I like it quite a lot
actually I knew going in that with the
potential power of the deck's Commander
a lot of the quality of the deck was
going to come down to how far the deck
leverages its commander synergies and
I'm not unhappy with where it's at
as I mentioned there are 11 cards that
will trigger vavo on most opposing turns
which is a decent count architect's
built and hypergeometric calculator
tells me that this means a 57% chance of
having one of these in the deck's
opening hand and a 78% chance to find
these in the first five draws of the
game given that all of these except for
carec the merciless cost five or less
Mana this means a high probability of
being able to set up a hefty draw engine
by turn five I do note that the number
of these cards that cost three or less
Mana is only four and this makes a lot
of sense honestly these cards combined
with the commander to produce a value
engine that will run away with games if
left unanswered and I can understand why
Wizards of the Coast would want to avoid
a lot of the lower cost options though
this precon does include easily the most
powerful of these Kar parasite which is
unexpected but cool as a group slug
enjoyer I love to see this powerful Tech
piece widely printed in a precon looking
at the other 15 vavo enablers there's a
wide variety of different effects here
six of these are blood artist effects
which make a decent bit of sense the
deck packs a good bit of removal and it
also runs a relatively High creature
count of 32 this deck doesn't have much
self-sacrifice but I expect that it
should still manage to get triggers
often enough for these to feel useful
the rest are a mixture of different
things that will lead to occasional life
loss on opposing turns overall these
have a good bit of variety and oddly I
feel like that's a good thing with a
commander this potent a lot of players
players building vavo are going to
default to cramming as many everyt pings
as possible into one deck and though
this does maximize the possible vavo
triggers it also flattens the play
pattern of the deck into one that is
predictably brutal for opponents this
will lead to the deck being Enemy Number
One at all times and not having many
cards dedicated to the backup plans that
will inevitably be necessary against
competent opponents by contrast having a
more diverse range of vavo enablers
means that this deck's play patterns and
relationship with its Commander are more
textured to opponents and a lot of these
enablers can also serve useful purposes
outside of enabling vavo so the instant
speed pink plan looks pretty good to me
as I mentioned earlier this deck's
removal Suite is likewise pretty good it
has seven pieces of targeted removal
four board wipes three removal engines
and one Carter he's not exactly removal
but he removes some scary things from my
presence by setting them at a different
player for a turn so that's basically
the same thing right there's also Brash
taunter I guess that's a removal engine
if you're opponent's creatures are puny
Beyond removal this deck also has
moderate amounts of ramp and non-c
Commander draw this is a deck that's
going to be drawing a lot of cards and
wanting to pay a lot of Commander tax so
having a healthy collection of Mana
rocks is absolutely a good thing non-c
Commander draw is also good expecting to
have the Commander in play at all times
is highly optimistic and fitting in a
healthy share of other draw is good
finally I support the choice to have
some amount of Life total stabilization
here as well which includes a few
different sources of Life gain
this is a deck that'll attract attacks
and it's good to be able to weather a
bit of that finally the Mana base here
looks quite solid if a little tapland
oriented in the lands alone we see 25
symbols each for red and black which are
fantastic counts there's a lovely
selection of different dual lands a
Tango a cycler a check land a pain land
a fast land a reveal land an odyssey
filter and most exciting of all a Graven
canons future side art this is great
Variety in lands for a two-color pron as
far as utility lands go the deck runs Le
ridden swamp and shiven Gorge to go with
vavo a witch's Clinic to Grant LifeLink
and spine Rock null as a Hideway Land
There are some minor tweaks that could
be made to tune up this Mana base and
I'll be doing one of them in my upgrade
to this deck but honestly this Mana base
is going to play just fine right out of
the box I play tested the deck 20 times
to get a feel for it and in the vast
majority of these the deck felt pretty
great curving out relatively smoothly
setting up threats and engines pretty
consistently and seeming generally well
poised to push later into the game in
some ways I find this deck tricky to
evaluate because it seems like a strong
deck but also a deck that will be a
lightning rod for opposing removal and
attacks however keeping that in mind
gives us a good idea of where to start
with upgrading so with that said let's
get into the things I do to try and
improve this deck in previous preon
reviews I've subbed out 20 cards but in
this one I'm going to drop that down to
15 this base is just really solid and 20
would feel like changing the deck more
than needed with that in mind let's get
into some of the cards I am not as is
thrilled by in this deck starting with
basically a whole category of card
sorcery speed slug cards these are cards
that deal damage to opponents but
usually or always on our turn rather
than our opponent's turns and which thus
can't trigger vabo these cards do have a
valid place in the deck obviously vavo
won't always be in play and cards that
slug opponents on our turn might be
better than their instant speed
counterparts sometimes however I do hold
these to a higher bar than instant speed
options and that is a bar that is simply
not met by most of these
enchanter's banee is theoretically an
enchantment hate option but in practice
it seems undertuned and gives opponents
way too many ways to get around being
harmed by it fear of burning alive is a
cute potential damage amplifier but this
deck doesn't have enough ways to enable
delirium and without delirium it's
basically just a six Mana 44 combustible
gearhulk is likewise a fun card and I
love it in my raata deck whose average
Mana value is stupid high but it too
costs a lot of mana and this deck
doesn't want the draw enough to Warrant
its inclusion speaking of draw stormfist
Crusader feeds the whole table cards
which might be okay in a draw hungry
deck but this deck has powerful enough
draw in the command Zone that giving
opponent resources isn't worth it I
exclude spiteful Visions for similar
reasons that one actually is a potent
vavo enabler but in a group select game
plan you don't want to be giving your
opponents resources to fight you with
because you will be attracting the ey of
the whole table there's a reason why my
ratos group slog deck does exactly the
opposite of giving opponents cards if
you think you can bribe opponents to be
nice with you with cards I think you're
underestimating how much your opponents
hate seeing their life total spiral
downward especially if it's in tandem
with you drawing cards a number of other
cards I cut because they simply don't do
quite enough to warrant keeping around
vile Smasher ability doesn't deal enough
damage to make up for his otherwise
meager body star athlete commits the
cardinal sin of giving opponents choices
and tectonic giant is fine but a bit
underwhelming here for four Mana grab
the prize and light up the stage are
fine as filtering and draw options
respectively but decidedly unimpressive
to me compared to some other options in
this sphere some other cards are strong
but feel out of place in this deck
braids is a sweet value engine but this
deck doesn't run many tokens or ETB
permanence that would be desirable
sacrifice options carec could be nice if
he sticks around but seven Mana is a bit
too much to pay for what he does in this
deck finally Barb flare Gremlin is a
card with potential but this deck isn't
well set up to break parody on the Mana
boost it gives Pro tip doubling your
opponent's Mana is generally not
recommended treasonous ogre is a
reasonably popular card and our Gremlin
friend here gives a three times better
rate for our opponents to translate life
into additional Mana what goes in in
place of these cards well most of my
additions follow One Core principle this
deck will make opponents Square the hell
up one form of this will be that the
commander easily forms many disgusting
value engines and as a result will be a
high priority Target for removal one way
I choose to combat this is protection
equipments specifically Swift foot boots
and champions Helm the other way I
choose to combat this is Glimpse The
Impossible which works as a potential
boost of Mana to recast the commander as
well as serving extra purposes of draw
and blockers I actually dislike a couple
of cards that I kept in this deck namely
ratos Lord of riots and Seance board but
these were kept in because I expect this
deck to do a lot of recasting its
commander and these cards are undeniably
helpful for that moving on I mentioned
squaring up earlier and aside from
removal the way I expect this to
manifest is this deck getting attacked
heavily opponents do not like feeling
like they're on a clock and cards that
do consistent player damage over time
will trigger exactly that feeling to
mitigate this I'm choosing to add some
defensive cards to the deck namely go
and life gain go also has the side
benefit of enabling the deck's blood
artist effects since opponents being in
combat with each other is a thing that
often results in creatures dying at no
cost to the goting player vengeful
ancestor is a class go granter that also
triggers vavo and frenzied gors spawn is
another go e2b creature with some added
utility for non-creature options disrupt
decorum is that lovely effect of goting
everything and spectacular Showdown is a
similar card that can also be used to
suddenly kill an opponent with an
enlarged vavo for Life gain Raphael fish
savior is a lovely package Life Link for
the commander and blockers in the form
of devils and these Devils can even
enable vabo after they block
I'm also choosing to add tainted bonds
which serves double duty as life total
stabilizer and vavo enabler with defense
and protection out of the way let's talk
about other vavo enablers I mentioned
earlier that a common choice for naive
players building vavo will be cramming
in as many cards as possible that deal
damage to opponents on each turn while I
do think that going all in on these
would amplify the deck's weaknesses to
removal and opposing aggression adding
in a handful of these to improve
consistency still seems useful now that
we've contained the deck's weaknesses a
bit and I do mean a handful as I
mentioned earlier this deck is already
doing pretty decently for vavo enablers
and I just want to add in a few more
lowcost ones roing Vortex is a good
enabler for vavo that damages players
each turn and I chose this over sulfuric
Vortex because this deck has a decent
bit of Life gain that it would be
unfortunate to incidentally prevent I'm
also adding one of my pet cards rug of
smothering which performs the role of
enabling bagabo when opponents cast
spells along with the similar Mage M
lizzard for a handful of miscellaneous
cards to finish things off I added the
mdfc hagr malling to replace Temple of
the false god and I also added another
removal spell I really like in Slug
decks called cut it's a mid removal
spell that can be cast from the
graveyard as a decent life loss spell
and I found this combo to be quite sweet
you get cheap removal for something when
you need it early and then a burst of
Life loss later when you're getting to
the stage of finishing off opponents my
final ad was a card I just like costic
Bronco it's a draw in engine it can slug
what's not to like so that's my upgrade
improved enablers more protection and
some defensive options to Keep Us Alive
through some irritated opponents even
without upgrades this is an impressive
deck and it's a deck that very clearly
positions itself as table enemy I like
this about it though the commander has
synergies that very much demand removal
immediately which is an Ever commmon
Commander Dynamic I don't care for as
much the fact that this is paired with a
game plan that is looking to whittle
down life totals quickly is pretty fun
I'm also interested to see if Wizards of
the Coast diversifies the game plans of
precons there have been a few different
more aggressive ones over the past year
and I hope we see more of that all right
that's all I have for this video if you
want to hear my thoughts on dusk as a
set I was in a podcast with the trinket
Mage and 33 elk last week and a link to
that is in the description with that
said here are some of my thoughts on
yesterday's Bannings see this total 180
on that now is interesting to see now
there have been some different opinions
on this some players want more some
players are upset that there wasn't more
uh and I understand that on some level
but also I think the cards they chose
were very clearly unique like it wasn't
it wasn't like they banned a couple of
cards that there are like seven very
similar cards to or anything um manac
Crypt in particular is so much more
powerful than anything else and it it is
clearly so much more of a problem in
terms of providing down sideless Mana
Advantage than basically every other
form of fast mana and jeweled Lotus is
likewise just crazy explosive uh
compared to just about any other ritual
I think the closest things we have are
like ancient tomb but like that's so
much worse of a rate than manac Crypt
and it's a land uh and manav vault which
likewise is a ritual if you're not
playing it alongside an untap source
it's a colorless ritual so it's not
really comparable the other group of
players who seem to have strong opinions
about this is expectedly the cedh
players and I think they're valid to
feel kind of upset about this